hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing once again
the recently announced HBO Harry Potter
TV series very brief update for those
unaware Warner Bros discovery made
headlines all around the world last week
when they confirmed plans for a new
Harry Potter series each season will be
authentic to the original books and
bring Harry Potter in these incredible
Adventures to new audiences around the
world while the Original Classic and
beloved films will remain at the core of
the franchise and available to watch
globally but as I discussed in my
previous video on the topic recasting
Harry Potter for HBO Max philosopher
stone I can't help but wonder about
casting with such big shoes to fill
casting for this series must be a bit
hectic that's why today I'm going to be
picking up where I left off in the last
video and casting for the second
installment of the Harry Potter series
the Chamber of Secrets like I mentioned
last time I want to see fresh faces for
all of the child actors so I'll be
sticking to strictly some of the main
adult characters introduced in the
second book Let's dive into it gilderoy
Lockhart recasting the five-time winner
of which Weekly's most charming smile
award won't be an easy task gilderoy
Lockhart is a famous Wizarding celebrity
and author introduced in the second book
that ends up with a teaching position at
Hogwarts taking over as the instructor
for defense against the dark arts
however as we come to later understand
the Lockhart in the public eye is
certainly not representative of the
fraudster underneath a man that built
his entire reputation on lies and deceit
over the course of the book film
Lockhart's true motivation slowly
unravel in the film adaptation of Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
Lockhart is played by Kenneth Branagh a
well-known British actor and director
with a career spanning several decades
branagh's portrayal of Lockhart was
praised for its comedic timing and
over-the-top personality capturing the
character's narcissism and
self-absorption to me Lockhart is
Kenneth Branagh however as the show is
likely to have a different tone than the
films it's important to find an actor
who can bring a fresh perspective to the
role while Kenneth branagh's portrayal
of Lockhart in the film was beloved by
many it's important to remember that
this is a new adaptation with new
opportunities for Creative choices my
first choice of the role would be Ewan
McGregor Eun McGregor to Scottish actor
that has risen to prominence through his
incredible performances in films like
Trainspotting the island Big Fish doctor
sleep and even Star Wars he has an
incredibly wide range as an actor having
performed well in both comedic and more
dramatic roles and they think that
you'll be able to perfectly encapsulate
both the likable and deceitful signs of
Lockhart's character but before we delve
in any further I need to say this have
you ever noticed that the Wizards in
Harry Potter have exceptionally
manicured beards the only problem is as
far as I know there's no Wizarding spell
that could be responsible which brings
me to the sponsor of today's video
manscaped the global men's Lifestyle
brand that's disrupting the bed Market
trusted by more than 8 million men
worldwide and U2 manscapes collection is
a revolutionary beard styling kit for
the Modern Man the beard hedger Pro kit
but what does the ideal beard grooming
routine look like and how can manscape's
new trimmer assist you in achieving your
best look tip one know what style is
best for you thanks to the beard hedger
we've now got more than 20 hair cutting
lengths to choose from all accessible
with just one guard and their Zoom wheel
tip 2 not all beard hairs grow the same
bids can be patchy that's why it's
important to hide these issues by taking
care of your skin and keeping their
hairs hydrated included in the beard
hedger kit is the manscaped
dermatologist tested beard oil tip 3 be
patient growing a proper beard takes
time which is why I want to keep things
tidy by trimming the edges with the
waterproof beard Hedges 7200 RPM Motor
and titanium coated t-blade tip 4 clean
your beard make it smell amazing along
with the kit comes manscapes vegan
shampoo and beard conditioner which
pamper your bid with nourishing oils and
antioxidants that rehydrate hair along
with the care to even get a free beard
accessory pack then the bed come beard
scissors and bed brush so go to
manscape.com today and get 20 off plus
free shipping when you use promo code HP
Theory at checkout that's 20 off plus
free international shipping with promo
code HP Theory at manscaped.com who knew
that the key to wizardly grooming was in
the Muggle world all along my next
choice would be Taryn egerton egerton is
a Welsh actor with a proven ability to
embody charming and charismatic
characters as demonstrated by his
performances in films like Kingsman and
Rocket Man through his previous acting
experience Edgar didn't have shown that
he can portray characters with a certain
level of Charisma and confidence that
will be necessary for a character like
Lockhart who is known for his good looks
and self-absorbed personality my last
choice that unfortunately won't happen
due to his age is Hugh Grant Hugh Grant
is my mind the perfect Lockhart next to
Brana of course and as it happens Grant
was actually offered the role of
Lockhart long long ago when they were
initially casting for the Chamber of
Secrets a role in ended up turning down
because he was too busy with other
projects with that said however Grant is
an expert at cheesy Charming it's just a
shame that he's 62 as that would not
work for the relatively young Professor
Lucius Malfoy next up we're casting
Lucy's Malfoy cruel Death Eater father
of Draco and husband to Narcissa in the
films Lucius was played by actor Jason
Isaacs who was able to perfectly
encapsulate the snide but sometimes
calamitous nature of his character I've
got quite a few choices for Lucius and
they are in no particular order first up
is Michael Fassbender Fastbender is a
well-known Irish German actor who Rose
to stardom for his performances in films
like glorious bastards X-Men first Class
and Steve Jobs Vass Bender is a
versatile actor with a wide range of
abilities that has demonstrated his
ability to play complex
multi-dimensional characters in a
variety of movies Lucy's Malfoy is a
complex character with many layers and
Fassbender could bring a unique
interpretation to the role but Bender's
commanding presence on screen would be a
great asset for playing Lucius Malfoy
who exudes power and privilege at least
initially Luke Evans Luke Evans is a
Welsh actor and singer who is famous for
his roles in movies such as Clash of the
Titans Immortals and the Three
Musketeers he was also appeared on stage
and performed in many of London's West
End Productions I don't know what it is
about Evans but I think you'd be able to
play the cold aristocratic and haughty
wizard quite well Henry Cavill Henry
Cavill is a British actor that began his
career with roles in the feature
adaptations of The Count of Monte Cristo
and I capture the castle one of his most
popular roles is Superman in the 2013
movie Man of Steel he's also very famous
for the Netflix series The Witcher where
he played geralt of Rivia and cavil's
got a great range and I think he'd do a
great job but portraying Lucius my only
issue is that he might not be too
believable as a bad guy wildcard Tom
Felton there's been some speculation
online that Tom Felton who played Draco
Malfoy in the Harry Potter series could
reprise the role of Lucius in the new
show while this is a fun idea I don't
really want to mishmash the Two Worlds
Tom Riddle next up we've got Tom Riddle
the one from the diary not to be
confused with adult Voldemort played by
Ray fines in the Chamber of Secrets this
young version of Tom Riddle was played
by actor Christian Coulson for this role
there aren't a lot of names that come to
mind but for some reason and I may be
totally off on this I think that Timothy
chalamet would do a good job that is so
long as he's able to master the accent
his boyish good looks at what I believe
to be potential to look menacing would
complement the role well I particularly
like to hear your suggestions for this
one as I couldn't really think of many
other names next up we've got Minerva
McGonagall Professor Minerva McGonagall
to stern but deeply concerned which that
serves as head of Gryffindor House in
the film she was portrayed by the iconic
actress Dame Maggie Smith one of the
first names I've seen thrust into the
mix is Olivia Coleman Coleman is a
British actress and producer that has
worked steadily as an actress on British
TV since the early to mid 2000s
appearing in hit shows like accused Mr
Sloan Peep Show and Broadchurch I think
she's got just the right range to play
McGonagall and I can imagine her now
calling students to attention wildcard
Emma Thompson Emma Thompson has actually
already appeared in Harry Potter in the
role of Sybil trelawny her Court civil
Nation Professor however there's
something about her that just feels
perfect for McGonagall my only issue is
that like I mentioned earlier I don't
really want to mix the Two Worlds let me
know if you agree in the comments the
dursleys Vernon and petunia next up
we've got Harry's awful uncle and Aunt
Vernon and petunia dursley a spiteful
pair that tormented for Harry nearly all
of his formative years Vernon does is
characterized by his pompous
narrow-minded in materialistic
personality he's highly critical of
anything related to magic and wizards
and has a strange obsession with
appearing respectable and normal to to
the outside world Vernon is another
character that's exceptionally difficult
to cast but with some research I was
able to come up with a few Replacements
the first name that came to mind was Ian
McNeese an actor famous for his
portrayal of government agent Harcourt
in the 1985 television series Edge of
Darkness McNeese has also gained
recognition for his roles in popular
films such as the Englishman who went up
a hill but came down a mountain and
Frank Herbert's June McNeese has a huge
personality a loud booming voice and a
perfect portly build that would fit
Vernon dursley my next choice would be
Hugh Bonneville a British actor known
for his extensive work in film
television and Stage Bonneville is
perhaps best well known for his
portrayal of Robert Crawley Earl of
Grantham in the ITV historical drama
series Downton Abbey Bonneville doesn't
exactly have the right build for Vernon
but if you put on a bit of weight I
think he could be pretty convincing but
junior dursley is characterized by her
jealousy bitterness and insecurity like
Vernon she is highly critical of
anything related to magic and is often
hostile towards Harry because of his
magical abilities however it is later
revealed that her animosity towards
Harry stems from her jealousy of her
sister Lily's magical abilities which
she always wanted for herself one of the
first actresses that comes to my mind is
Tilda Swinton until the Swinton is a
Scottish actress known for her roles in
both independent Art House films and
Blockbusters over the course of her
career she's been cast in a very diverse
array of roles one of the most
impressive in my opinion being her role
as the White Witch in The Chronicles of
Narnia in whatever film I see her in she
always has a lot of screen presence and
with her Scottish background I'm sure
she would slot in perfectly with the
Harry Potter set
Swinton was actually originally
considered for the role of Professor
triloni the quirky unusual and perhaps
sometimes deluded divination Professor
however the role of trelawny was
eventually given to actress Emma
Thompson perhaps this is swinton's
opportunity to join Harry Potter once
and for all
and that's it for this video let me know
what you think of my choices and be sure
to comment your own choices down below
also be sure to check out my first video
on this subject where I cover casting
for the first film also stay on the
lookout for part three when I cover
Prisoner of Azkaban until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live